[Music]
welcome back to another episode of
what's up pro fellow walter
you beat me to it i had to try
how are you doing it's cold today yeah
i haven't we haven't felt this cold
weather in a long time but we won't
mention it too loud because people in
canada and europe will laugh at us we
say it's cold anything below 25 is
freezing 25 degrees celsius yes it's
freezing
and when it gets to 20 or 19 it's time
to rack
wrap an electric blanket around you
so that's why i say the people in under
other countries will laugh at us but for
us it's cold yes yes it's very cold
martin we're going to talk about
parallels for our time i think this
links with
the a previous one where we spoke about
the remnant church
because uh the parallels for our time
well
they show us that we are actually on
track
for
the various developments that are taking
place yes so let's open with a word of
prayer then get into it
our heavenly father we are so blessed
and so
unworthy but we ask that you please help
us to bring this message still to the
to the world and to enlighten our minds
with the discussion
and help us through this in jesus name
amen amen
all right martin
let's look at the history of the
reformation
and then the events from 1843 to 1844
now really martin if you think about it
what happened in 1843 and 1844
is basically a reinstatement
of the reformation guess
with a little bit of extra light
with regards to the law and the
sanctuary
and it's also
in the reformation
people had to come out
of babylon come out of the
system yes and even within that system
if you move it along from 1844 to 1888
there was
this tremendous truth of righteousness
by faith but it was not a new truth the
reformers had already discovered it
that's it so the reformers had already
a type yes so basically what happened
in 1843 and 1844 when when the law was
discovered
and it was such a big thing because the
world had made void the law
that the pendulum swung
in the direction of the law
and in the process seemed to neglect
righteousness by faith
and so at some stage the pendulum had to
swing back
towards righteousness by faith
but there was this magnetic attraction
over here
from the law
and so they had various photographs or
not photographs but paintings
where they had christ
there and the law there and then christ
there and the lord there
and actually
the two should be superimposed because
you cannot you cannot remove or separate
the one from the other
you cannot separate the character from
the man that's because the character
makes the man
and i've kept my father's commandments
therefore the character of christ is in
harmony with the law
and so any form of separation
is a pendulum swing activity and if you
then take the 1843-44
that's similar to the reformation you've
got again this cleansing of doctrines
and everything happening
and i believe we are
spiritually once again
at that stage yes and
all of these truths were discovered
and now there is a massive attack again
on the pillars that make this movement
what it is
which is just the reformation continued
movement
and to try and uproot it again
but that's the work of the jesuits they
want to uproot truth
so there are certain parallels with our
times as well and we have to learn from
this past
what we should do to prevent ourselves
from making the same mistakes that the
majority of people did in those times so
you know these parallels are so
fascinating so shall we start with the
reformation
so god raised up men to cry against the
existing sins of the papal church and
carry forward the reformation
through those chosen men rays of light
began to scatter the darkness and very
many joyfully received the light and
walked in it and when one witness was
slain two or more were raised up to fill
his place but satan was not satisfied he
could only have power of the body
he could not make believers yield their
faith and hope and even in death they
triumphed with a bright hope of
immortality at the resurrection of the
just
while the church was persecuted
they were united and loving
they were strong in god sinners were not
permitted to unite themselves with it
neither the deceiver nor the deceived
those only who were willing to forsake
all for christ could be his disciples
they loved to be poor humble and
christ-like interesting though
a wonderful statement they loved to be
poor
humble and christ-like for the sake of
christ yeah
interesting
and
only under persecution
could she
achieve this cleansing so this was the
physical persecution
but satan wasn't satisfied with this
because he saw that the more he
physically persecuted the more they
physically suffered the stronger they
stood
all right
so suddenly his angels decided that
there was a more successful way to
destroy souls and more certain in the
end satan decided
that he must come in a milder form
he had corrupted the doctrines of the
bible
and traditions which were the ruin of
millions were taking deep root he
restrained his hate
and decided not to urge on his disciple
to such better persecution
but lead on the church to contend not
for the faith once delivered to the
saints
but for various traditions
as he led on the church to receive
favors and honours of the world
under the false pretense of benefiting
them she began to lose favor with god
gradually the church lost her power
as she shunned to declare the straight
truths which shut out the lovers of
pleasure
and friends of the world
he's quite a strategist right a
master
now martin if you think about it
even early on in the experience of early
christians
they went
to martyrdom
singing
they were put into the colosseum they
were torn apart by animals they were
crucified
and he couldn't destroy them right
he couldn't get rid of them so he had to
bring the world into the church and
bring a compromise and through
compromise he destroyed them
but now he wanted this compromised
church to be the representative
and that's quite a strategy
now in the past
when you decided to become a christian
if you were a pagan
you studied the word of god
and you came to the conclusion that this
was the truth
and if you believed with your whole
heart as it says in acts chapter 8
then you were baptized
and you came into the church
in other words baptism was a barrier
and once you believed with your whole
heart
means you were an adult with
capacity to discern between falsehood
and error
then you were baptized
and so satan had to devise a plan
to stop this because he wanted the world
in the church
and so he invented infant baptism
because by inventing infant baptism you
cut out if you believe with your whole
heart and you bring the world into the
church
and you feed them traditions
and then you have a worldly church
representing the master of deception
clever very clever very clever that's
how he works
well
if we pull this way all the way through
to the remnant
if you want to be part of the remnant
you have to know what the remnant
believes why did the remnant become a
remnant based on the pillars of
adventism and which isn't it important
then to keep the world out of the church
you have to keep the world out of the
church and not bring the world into the
church is there a movement to bring the
world into the church
never mind bring a movement to bringing
it in a very successful operation
has been performed and many many of our
churches became so worldly that they
left the ranks
so spiritual gifts volume one
is what we are quoting from largely in
this study right yes
the church is not the separate and
peculiar people she was when the fires
of persecution were kindled against her
i saw that if the church had always
retained a holy and peculiar character
the power of the holy spirit which was
imparted to the disciples would be with
her
the sick would be healed devils would be
rebuked and cast out
and she would be mighty and a terror to
her enemies
i saw that a very large company
professed the name of christ
but god does not recognize them as his
he has no pleasure in them satan seemed
to assume a religious character and was
very willing that the people should
think they were christians
he was very willing that they should
believe in jesus his crucifixion and his
resurrection
but they shouldn't believe any of the
distinctive truths
i've not come to abolish the law i have
come to fulfill it
not one chart or one testle very verily
i say unto you not one jot or one title
will by any means disappear from the law
they don't like that right no so this is
what happens to a church when
they
listen to these doctrines of devils yes
satan and his angels fully believed all
this themselves and trembled
but if this faith does not provoke to
good works and lead those who profess it
to imitate self-denying life of christ
he is not disturbed for they merely
assume the christian name
while their hearts are still carnal
he can use them in his service better
than if they made no profession
this is just as relevant
currently as it was
for the reformation
for the
1883-4 message
so if we study the way
in which he undermined the reformation
and what strategy worked
then we can expect that we will find
that strategy
in the in the church today yes
those outside of the remnant and inside
of the remnant
the ministers preach smooth things to
suit carnal professors
this is just as satan would have it they
dare not preach jesus and the cutting
truths of the bible for if they should
these carnal professors would not hear
them
many of them are wealthy and must be
retained in the church although they are
no more fit to be there than satan and
his angels
pleasing fables are taught and readily
received but if the truth should be
preached in its purity
it would soon shut out hypocrites and
sinners
and there's no difference between the
professed followers of christ and the
world
so that's exactly what will happen
so when we see
a worldly situation within the church
it just means that his strategy is
working that's it
and he's more than satisfied with it as
it is if that's the case okay
i saw that if the false covering could
be torn off from the members of the
churches there would be revealed such
iniquity
vileness and corruption
that the most diffident child of god
would have no hesitancy in calling them
by their right name children of their
father the devil
for his works they do those are pretty
straight words so martin do we have
characters of this nature in the church
yes now we've discussed the church
before
and we know that they are in the church
even the most iniquitous will be in the
church
does that make the church babylon no
no so actually
this is a plea
to people in the church and outside but
even but
let's say in the church now
to do introspection like we've mentioned
in the previous one as well so we have
to martin go on our knees and say create
in me a right mind and a right spirit
wash me with hyssop and i shall be
whiter than snow
no matter how great you think you are or
how much you have achieved
there is a greater amount that you have
not achieved
so martin
why are we talking about this in the
first place
to get people to start real like we just
mentioned introspection to make sure
that i'm not
falling into the trap
of
going with the world
and the wrong side now those reformers
that were sitting in dungeons waiting to
be burnt at the stake
what was going through their mind
well they were singing songs so i think
their mind were fixed on on god all
right but obviously there had to be some
their sins must have gone before them
yes
there must have been some serious
thinking and if you take for example
cranmer
he was the archbishop of of canterbury
and he was willing to go to the stake
and then
he slipped
and he recanted
and then they brought him before the
people and they said to him
confess to the people what you just
confessed that you have recanted and
that rome is right after all and when he
saw the people he took courage
isn't he the one that said burn my hands
first i think so put his fingers in the
fire because with those hands he had
signed his recantation
and he held them there until they fell
off
now it's amazing right
so
yes we need to have serious
introspection
revelation 14 67 brings us
the message of the three angels or the
beginning of that message
and i saw another angel fly in the midst
of heaven having the everlasting gospel
to preach unto them that dwell on the
earth and to every nation and kindred
and tongue and people saying with a loud
voice fear god and give glory to him
for the hour of his judgment is come
and worship him that made heaven and
earth and the sea and the fountains of
water so the anti-typical day of
atonement had arrived yes the close of
the 2300
days
and
judgment
now when you think about judgment
you must think of
your situation
are you guilty answer is yes i'm guilty
all right then the question must be have
my sins gone before me that's a question
are they recorded that they have gone
before me
have they been blotted out
that is the question right
that's it
i saw that god was in the proclamation
of the time in 1843
it was his design to arouse the people
and bring them to a testing point where
they should decide
ministers were convicted and convinced
of the correctness of the position
taking on the prophetic periods
and they left their pride their salaries
and their churches to go forth from
place to place and proclaim the message
but as the message from heaven could
find a place in the hearts of but a very
few of the professed ministers of christ
the work was laid upon many who were
not preachers
there were about 250 preachers
from churches that had accepted the
message
but there were far more lay people right
50 000 total that's it once again
put this
into what's happening today
we can expect that the lay people will
do the bulk of the work
the people were moved everywhere the
message reached them sinners repented
wept and prayed for forgiveness
and those whose life had been marked
with dishonesty were anxious to make
restitution so martin is all about a
state of mind that's it so when the
judgment comes it's all about a state of
mind like you've just said
creating me a new mind lord
because if we don't accept this first
message
we're not going to accept the second and
third
all right if we continue with the story
what happened under the preaching of the
first angels message parents felt the
deepest solicitude for their children
those who received the message labored
with their unconverted friends and
relatives
and with their souls bowed with the
weight of solemn message warmed and
entreated them to prepare for the coming
of the son of man
martin do you remember what it was like
when you first discovered this truth
this
could you keep it in no this was what
happened
did you come up against the brick wall
oh yes
did you bash your head
but you felt compelled
why is it that so few in the church feel
compelled
i think they don't realize
how close we are
and maybe they're not truly converted
yet or they've become complacent they've
gone to sleep
definitely you've got the virgins there
so the hymn that they are singing is
snoring
okay
so there was to be warning and
entreatment
to prepare for the coming of the son of
man
those cases were the most hardened that
would not yield to such a weight of
evidence set home by heartfelt warnings
this soul-purifying work led
the affections away from worldly things
to a consecration never before
experienced thousands were led to
embrace the truth preached by william
miller
and servants of god were raised up in
the spirit and power of elijah to
proclaim the message
and those who preached this solemn
message like john the forerunner of
jesus
felt compelled to lay the axe at the
root of the tree
and call upon men to bring forth fruits
meet for repentance
do we see this spirit in the church
no
but we need to
we have to get to this because
as the message
the hour of his judgment judgment has
come changed no
the judgment is ongoing still and it's
closer to its end than ever before than
it was when this was given so shouldn't
the south become louder
isn't the final one a loud cry
it's swelling into a loud cry now is the
time to do exactly what we read these
people had to do in 1843
the preaching of a definite time called
forth great opposition from all classes
from the ministers and the pulpit down
to the most reckless heaven-daring
sinner
so if you dare to say the time is close
even if you don't give a precise time
are you still in trouble today oh
definitely because now you can become
complacent because that's a nice
scapegoat oh we're not allowed to
mention
any nearness of time anymore
so no man knoweth the day and the hour
was heard from the hypocritical
ministers and the bald scoffer neither
would be instructed and corrected on the
use made of the text by those who were
pointing to the year
when they believed the prophetic periods
would run out and to the signs which
showed christ near even at the doors
let's have a question
if there is a prophetic period given in
the bible and there's a beginning and
there is an end
then that is cast in concrete isn't it
that's it you can't change it and if the
first portion
is fulfilled to the letter
then the second portion must be
fulfilled to the letter as well right
now the first portion
applied to the jews
the second portion
applies to the
world and there is a cut-off date
the end of that
long
prophetic period
and no matter how you calculate it it
ends
in 1844
so something must have happened in 1844
and as we have discussed many times all
the isms started in 1844 whether we're
talking about spiritism whether we're
talking about
darwinism whether we're talking about
extensionalism whether we're talking
about whatever
ecumenism
they all started in 1844 that's not
coincidence
moreover the means to spread the gospel
in other words the
electronic media and
the transport
facilities they all started in 1844
so this is not a coincidence no
and it's the same as we've read
earlier
satan
had to when this message of the hour of
his judgment has come
he had to do his infiltration and his
counteract he had to counteract it by
every means possible
so many shepherds of the flock who
professed to love jesus said they had no
opposition to the preaching of christ's
coming
but they objected to the definite time
now the trouble was that the prophecy
had a definite time
the only mistake was they misinterpreted
the event yeah
because the event was the hour of his
judgment has come not the hour of his
coming had come here
god's all-seeing eye read the hearts
they did not love jesus near
isn't that the bottom line
exactly you took the words out of my
mouth that's what it's about so they
said no we don't have a problem with
jesus coming
we have a problem with this time that
you're setting so if you say in the time
that we are living in the six thousand
years are coming to an end will you be
in trouble yes
because you said a certain definite time
when you say that
no no
but what is the underlying problem
this is the underlying problem they
don't want jesus coming to be near
they knew that their unchristian lives
would not stand the test for they were
not walking in the humble path laid out
by him
these false shepherds stood in the way
of the work of god
it's very interesting
strong words
these spiritual gift volumes
they're very informative because they
still
say it as it is
right
it's really worthwhile for anybody to go
and read those spiritual gift volumes
the truth spoken in its convincing power
to the people aroused them and like the
jailer they began to inquire what must i
do to be saved
but these shepherds step between the
truth and the people and preach smooth
things to lead them from the truth
martin don't they say this is alarmist
preaching
exactly
they united with satan and his angels
and cried peace peace when there was no
peace
many ministers would not accept this
saving message themselves and those who
would receive it they hindered
the blood of souls is upon them
preachers and people joined to oppose
this message from heaven
so martin what happened then
right at the end will happen again
so the message will go forth with great
opposition
from both within the world as well as
from within and many of the preachers
will be arrayed against it
i saw
that if professed christians had loved
their savior's appearing
if their affections were placed on him
if they felt that there was none upon
earth to be compared with him they would
have hailed with joy the first
intimation of his coming
but the dislike they manifested as they
heard of their lord's coming was a
decided proof that they did not love him
satan and his angels triumphed and cast
it in the face of jesus christ and his
holy angels that his professed people
had so little love for jesus that they
did not desire his second appearing
so modern history has a way of repeating
itself
we must be careful
that we are so scared of what the world
would say and how we would look in
people's eyes
that we fall under this that we don't
look as if we desire the second coming
all right now if you were god
would you perhaps then permit
let's put it that way the devil
of bringing about the time
of trouble
of such proportions that you actually
start
longing for the coming of christ for
sure
he's again like in the reformation like
in this time he's again busy with the
purifying
of the church
so his hand covered a mistake in the
reckoning of the prophetic periods
actually there was no mistake
in the prophetic periods other than that
they had ignored that zero year
that was in 1843 that was in 1843
and then in 1844 there was a mistake in
the interpretation of the event so there
were actually two mistakes
okay but what did god did like you've
just mentioned
was this in god's plan it must have been
in god's plan
because did the disciples
understand when jesus said that it was
going to be crucified no was it in their
plan no no
they had mixed up the first and the
second coming of christ
they were expecting the second coming
but they were dealing with the first
coming
and they were totally unprepared for it
so what happened when christ was
crucified wasn't there a great
scattering yeah
they went and hid in the upper room
they didn't go and
do sermons
so
it seems that we've had this event more
than once in history
and it is in the cleansing event that's
it so there was a mistake
there was a misinterpretation
it led to a tremendous disappointment in
the time of the disciples here there was
a mistake there was a misinterpretation
it led to a great disappointment why
can't people see that this is one of the
ways in which god cleanses his church
so you can't discard the bible because
of the message that the disciples
brought because they had a great
disappointment just as little as you can
discard
this church because of the
disappointment they had okay now the
prophetic period is it in the bible yes
so if it's there is it to be studied
definitely
so as soon as you study it and you come
to a conclusion
you're condemned already and if the
conclusion turns out to be incorrect
then you're doubly condemned what a
beautiful strategy does it make the
prophecy wrong
no
those who were looking for their lord
did not discover it then the most
learned men who opposed
the time also failed to see the mistake
god designed that his people should meet
with a disappointment
the time passed some of our preachers
are saying this is just a pathetic
excuse
excuse me there is the prophecy
you cannot
annul it
the time passed and those who had looked
with joyful expectation for their savior
were sad and disheartened
while those who had not loved the
appearing of jesus but embraced the
message through fear were pleased that
he did not come at the time of
expectation
the profession had not affected their
hearts and purified their lives
so again you've had you had a cleansing
action
and you could actually see what category
people belong to
because the moment they started mocking
even though they stood right next to you
five minutes before
shows you that their conversion was
half-hearted exactly it's a cleansing
again it's like the woman on the boat in
the storm
where they fall on that where she fell
on their knees and prayed that god
should protect them and that she should
change her life
if he did and then the the storm abated
and she was saved from the petals of the
storm and went straight back to our old
life
and ellen white asked excuse me what
about your your promise that you were
made oh that was then
we'll have things like that similar
so
the purpose of the first angel was to
announce the judgment we are living in
the anti-typical day of atonement
and once they had discovered the reasons
for their false interpretation
and the sanctuary message
then they were ready
for the next great episode right and
even now we've read about the
disappointment but it's biblical yes so
if you go to revelation chapter 10
you actually have the story recorded
and i went unto the angel and said unto
him give me the little book and he said
unto me take it and eat it it shall make
thy belly bitter
but it shall be in thy mouth sweet as
honey
now when you eat something what comes
first martin the mouth of the stomach
the mouth so there was a sweet yes and
it turned to better
the lord is coming
joy
he didn't not come
disappointment
so if we unpack it i saw a number of
companies who seem to be bound together
by chords many of these companies were
in total darkness
their eyes were directed downwards to
the earth and there seemed to be no
connection between them and jesus
beams of light from jesus like rays of
light from the sun were imparted to them
and angel bit me look carefully
and i saw an angel watching over every
one of those who had a ray of light
while evil angels surrounded those who
were in darkness
i heard the voice of an angel cry fear
god and give glory to him for the hour
of his judgment of come a glorious light
rested upon these companies to enlighten
all who would receive it
so the light was
presented to everyone right yes to all
these churches these companies were
churches okay who received it only a few
once again er
it was a cleansing
so the loud cry of the third angel's
message
who will it go to
the whole world
and how many will receive it
unfortunately only a few
okay
and as many as were breaking the courts
which bound them
men belonging to these different
companies who were
revered by them passed through the
companies
and some with pleasing words and other
with wrathful looks and threatening
jesters
fastened the cords which were weakening
and were constantly saying god is with
us we stand in the light we have the
truth
i inquired who these men were
i was told that they were ministers and
leading men who had rejected the light
themselves and were unwilling that
others should receive it
i saw those who cherish the light
looking with interest and ardent desire
upwards expecting jesus to come and take
them to himself
sir martin
the greatest problem at the end
will come from what class
the leadership in the church
ministers ministers ministers
have you had bible studies with people
and they are absolutely smitten by what
they read in the bible
and then they go and have a discussion
with their minister
and lose all interest
so whose word bears the greatest
authority then with them the word of god
or the word of the minister the word of
the minister and it's a sad state of
affairs
that happens in every denomination yes
and if we can put this up to today again
messages and circumstances have been
showing us the time is close
must be
and what was the reaction of
a majority of people
was it the same as we've just seen
they reacted to the first angels message
that those time that time
imagine if you have a love for the truth
and you discuss the truth
then
would you not jointly imagine that
people would study together and come to
a joint conclusion
but what i am seeing is
camps are forming
and those camps
never the twins shall meet
they're saying
they're fasting the courts now this
course is not courts of faith this
course is chords of oh we've got this
certain thing that we've got we know
what the truth is and we stand by it
and we will not entertain your point of
view no matter how many verses you give
us is that right
do we see this happening in our church
and then of course there followed
another angel
that was able to say babylon has fallen
is fallen that great city because she
made all the nations drink of the wine
of the wrath of her fornication but if
you did not accept the first angels
message could you be part of the second
angel no
unfortunately you can't
you can't no
because you will actually be part of
babylon and you won't know that it's
fallen that's it so you must put this in
spiritual as well if your mind
is still in babylon and you didn't
receive this
hour of judgment and the second coming
is at hand
you're not going to receive the second
message to get your mind out of babylon
you won't be able to be part of the
message
and if you're not part of the second
angel's message will you be part of the
third angels message no definitely not
no you won't right
so how important this is that you accept
the first angel
utmost importance it's life and death so
why did they become babylon
because they refused to accept the first
angel's message right
and by the way the hour of his judgment
has come
worship him who made
the heavens the earth the sea and the
springs of water
it's in the sabbath commandment isn't it
that's it and you cannot have a judgment
without a law
so the first angels message
bring law and grace into harmony they
kiss each other
right
justice and mercy kiss each other in the
first angel's message
but you only need mercy if you are a
transgressor
so you must be a transgressor of the law
so when you receive the message then you
must also accept that you are being
judged by the law
and when you are
have this feeling that you are being
judged by the law
that means you better repent that's it
you have to
so it's it's a logical sequence
so once you have repented
then you can be baptized
either physically or in the spirit right
yeah
so
they all go together it just shows you
how important it is to already adhere to
the first angel
so when you accept the first angels
message
you embrace the law
that's it you also embrace the sabbath
worship him were made
because that's in the sabbath
commandment
and then
you can say babylon has fallen
because they've drunken of the wine the
false doctrine of her apostasy if i may
rephrase that verse right
okay so what is part of the false
doctrine of her apostasy a false sabbath
false sabbath first angel tells you that
quite clearly
so near the close of the second angels
message i saw a great light from heaven
shining upon the people of god
the rays of this light seemed bright as
the sun and i heard the voices of angels
crying behold the bridegroom cometh go
ye out to meet him
so
the
expectancy of christ's coming is it
greater as we proceed faster through the
angel's message or does it become less
louder and louder it it grows at this
stage
if you didn't receive the first one you
won't be part of this growing
um
loud cry
all right
so the cry becomes louder that the
bridegroom is coming because obviously
you are progressing towards that event
now if you had
expectation of the nearness in the first
angel
then you must have a greater expectation
as you see the apostasy
now can we break it down
even
to a situation within the church
i definitely
if we we continue to look at
signs
out there in the world
but obviously
when you see these things that are
mentioned in the spirit of prophecy in
the bible
about what will happen inside the church
then it's also an indication of how near
the coming of christ is so are you
trying to tell me
that when i see signs of great apostasy
within the church
i should lift up my head and rejoice
because the coming of the lord is near
definitely but i should also lift up my
voice
and tell the house of israel their sins
you have to it's a command we have to
all right so
behold the bridegroom cometh go ye out
to meet him
so the midnight cry was given
to give power to the second angel's
message
angels were sent from heaven to wake up
the discouraged saints and prepare them
for the great work before them
the most talented men
were not the first to receive this
message
angels were sent to the humble devoted
ones and constrained them to raise the
cry behold the bridegroom cometh go ye
out to meet him
those who received it looked very happy
they fixed their eyes up to heaven and
longed for the appearing of jesus
somewhere in great distress weeping and
praying
their eyes seemed to be fixed upon
themselves and they dared not look
upward
a precious light from heaven parted the
darkness from them and their eyes
which had been fixed in despair upon
themselves were turned upwards while
gratitude and holy joy were expressed
upon every feature
jesus and all the angelic hosts looked
with approbation upon the faithful
waiting ones
those who rejected and opposed the light
of the first angel's message
lost the light of the second
and could not be benefited by the power
and glory which attended the message
behold the bridegroom cometh
jesus turned from them
with a frown
that's rather
enlightening so you cannot be benefited
by the second message if you haven't
accepted the first message
and if you embrace the second message
then surely you must ask yourself what
is the wine that i must avoid
because that wine
will be
bought
and
presented to you
along with the seat
all right now
it's a woman
and she has a beaker a cup
filled with abominations we read about
it in revelation chapter 17
and
everybody in the reformation period knew
exactly who that woman was today
they are sitting at a table drinking
from that cup
and totally forgetting the history
so can they then be part of the third
angel if they're not even part of the
second angel no
if you say rome has changed
are you part of the second angel no
definitely not right
if you are part of the reformed churches
and they're sitting in economical
councils
uniting and compromising on points of
doctrine can you be part of the second
angel's message also not no
okay
so they had slighted and rejected him
those who received the message were
wrapped in a cloud of glory they waited
and watched and prayed to know the will
of god
they greatly feared to offend him the
message given from heaven enraged satan
and his angels
and those who professed to love jesus
but despised his coming
scorned and derided the faithful
trusting ones
so we have the development of two cabs
come out of my people
or come and join me in an economical
festivity that's it
and the main message
of the church of these people are
jesus is on his way all right now
let's take it back again to the to the
remnant
are there people within the remnant
that are not part of the second angels
message
unfortunately yes do we read their
articles yes roma's changed do we read
articles
rome is not the antichrist
are they our prominent people or are
they
not prominent people they're prominent
people just as we've read they would be
all right now if they're not part of the
second angel because they do not
recognize that there is a babylon
then can they be part of the third angel
no
is this a serious issue
definitely
okay
so what do these people do that embraced
the message they renounced the world
tore their affections from it and
sacrificed their earthly interests
they were not free from errors and i saw
the mercy and goodness of god in sending
a warning to the people of earth
and repeated messages to bring them
up to a point of time to lead them to a
diligent search of themselves
that they might divest themselves of
errors which have been handed down from
heathen and papists
that message can't sit well with some
with even within the church
through these messages god has been
bringing out his people where he can
work for them in greater power and where
they can keep all his commandments but
this cleansing is taking place within
the church i believe it as well you
believe it
so how important is it that we make sure
that we're part of this group it's
utterly important and diligent search of
ourselves so when we
on occasion
show what is being preached by some of
the preachers in this church of ours
is that
criticism misapplied or is it essential
to warn people
that want to follow the straight and
narrow road it's essential we've even
seen it in ezekiel 8.
so jesus did not come to earth as the
waiting joyful company expected to
cleanse the sanctuary by purifying the
earth by fire
i saw that they were correct in their
reckoning of the prophetic periods
prophetic time closed in 1844 their
mistake consisted in not understanding
what the sanctuary was that's what we
said in the beginning
and the nature of its cleansing jesus
did not enter the most holy place to
cleanse the sanctuary at the ending of
the days
time was fulfilled but
where was their savior
they lost him
i was then shown the disappointment of
the disciples as they came to the
sepulcher and found not the body of
jesus
said mary
they've taken away my lord
martin this is a fascinating parallel
definitely
so when you go to a great disappointment
the disciples had one
and he had told them that he will rise
on the third day didn't he
and they went to the sepulcher and he
wasn't there we've lost him we've lost
him
so when he went from the first chamber
to the second chamber did some lose him
yes
unfortunately they've taken him away and
this is so important because there's so
many people that still say that jesus
went into the directly into the most
holy at his ascension yes we had that
movement within our church and it is not
uh
abating in any form or fashion it is
actually increasing
so they've taken the lord away
i find that's very interesting so we had
basically a repetition
of what happened
at the crucifixion
i know not where they have laid him
now
is it possible
for someone
then to take the place of jesus yes
and we actually read that satan can take
the place and fix the affections upon
himself even jesus is not there he's
gone into
the second chamber now what does that
imply
if we if we have to unpack it it simply
implies
it doesn't imply that jesus is gone
it doesn't mean that he's locked himself
in another room
it means we have gone into the era
when the standard of judgment will be
made prominent
when the law will be made prominent
and if you do not enter with him into
that mindset
then you will reign in or remain in the
mindset the law has been done away with
exactly and then the master of do what
thou wilt is the whole of the law
will take the place of jesus and receive
the worship because he says you can do
whatever you want because there's no law
there's no law
and then they will be worshiping this
false jesus
but the real jesus
is where
those are that keep the commandments of
god and hold to the testimony these
others might claim that they hold to the
testimony but they don't keep the
commandments of god so they have another
leader yes
okay
angels told the sorrowing disciples that
their lord has risen
and would go before them into galilee i
saw that the disappointment of those who
believed in the coming of the lord in
was not equal to the disappointment of
the disciples
prophecy was fulfilled in the first and
second angels message they were given at
the right time
and accomplished the work god designed
they should
all right martin so it was not equal why
would you think it wasn't equal because
they walked with the lord
physically
so their disappointment was even even
worse it was so much more intense
here was a spiritual application and you
could easily be put on the sideline
but the event had a similar consequence
that's why she's earlier said she saw
the same
the disappointment
it's still a parallel
so then we move martin to the third
angel saying with a loud voice if any
man worship the beast and his image and
receive his mark in the foreign
etc
then we know what the rest of the verse
says
and then it follows and says here's the
patience of the saints here they that
keep the commandments of god and have
the faith of jesus
and i heard a voice from heaven saying
unto me right blesses are the dead which
die in the lord from henceforth
yea says the spirit that they may rest
from their labors and their works do
follow them so martin
was there going to be a period of time
from
understanding the third angel's message
until the coming yes where people still
going to die yes but if they died in the
third angel's message blessed were they
all right so it wasn't going to come
immediately it was going to take a
period of time you know these prophecies
are actually amazing aren't they it's
amazing and another thing is still if
you don't follow you have to come
through
follow the first one then you will
accept the second one you cannot do it
in reverse gear no anything you have to
you have to understand what it is all
about so you must understand who babylon
is
she's fallen
you must understand what the wine is
you must avoid drinking the wine
yes you must be separate yeah
right that's the second angel's message
yes the first one is you have to be
looking forward to jesus that's on his
way yes and you have to understand the
the judgment and the sabbath and the
basis for the judgment so there's a
whole doctrinal set that has to develop
if you want to be part of the third
angels message
now the third angel's message is that
you mustn't receive the mark of the
beast
that means you must understand who the
beast is
then you mustn't receive the mark of the
image because the image is going to be
like the beast
all right that's it he also has a mark
but the mark actually belongs to the
first beast but he's accepted it
so he's going to push for it so he must
understand who that is that's
protestantism
protestantism and the state combining
together to enforce the mark in your
mind in your forehead
or to at least force you to adhere to
their dictates whether you want to or
not
and if you succumb to that pressure you
receive the mark
so you must resist it
so you need to know who the beast is
did the reformers know who the beast was
yes
did the reformers know who the image was
no
no no
the image wasn't there yet ah it hadn't
formed
around one so where are we now do we
know who the image is yes why because
prophetic prophecy fulfilled and we can
see it in history and the
first angels message that was received
in the second angel's message all this
the remnant church
brought it to the world all right now
we're going to look at current events
again in our next one
because we always try to alternate
current events with prophetic insights
right
and we will see that the image has
formed that's it
and anybody who wants to deny that the
image has formed is in serious trouble
because they just have to look at the
supreme court of america
and what the newspapers are shouting
that the image is being formed but if
you don't and then that's what's going
to come out
if we show that and you don't accept
that the image is formed and all of this
it means you haven't accepted the first
and second angels messages and therefore
you have no comprehension of the third
does that apply even to some of our
leading people it definitely applies to
the church as well they claim that the
image has informed didn't they just
recently even claim that the image
hasn't formed no but then you also got
the other sad part that sometimes they
acknowledge there's an image
but then
their fruits are a little bit different
all right so some might preach against
the beast
but then implement what the beast wants
that's a bit of a problem
okay
so martin
all of this implies a certain basic
knowledge
you must know who the beast is the
reformers told us who the beast is the
reformers knew what the beast was who
the beast was the reformers have decided
to reject that notion
and rather climb into bed with the beast
thereby forming the image
and the image is shouting louder than
the beast could ever have shouted
and clamoring for
whatever it is that the beast wants
so it's like herodias telling salome
that she wants the head of john the
baptist
and they will receive the mark and the
foreign in other words they will think
like her because they have come to see
matters in the same light
and those that do not even know it will
receive it in the hand because what's
the big deal right yeah but actually
you're dealing with the authority of god
versus the authority of man that's what
the sabbath issue is about
so here is the patience of the saints
here are they that keep the commandments
of god and the faith of jesus
patience means that you have to endure
the sight of this for quite a while
and they will be
from the going forth of that message to
the culmination
there will be a period of time where
people will
die and be buried and new ones will come
and the message will go forth
so as the ministration of jesus closed
in the holy place and he passed into the
holiest and stood before the ark
containing the law of god
he sent another mighty angel to earth
with the third message
he placed a parchment in the angel's
hand and as he descended to the earth in
majesty and power
he proclaimed a fearful one warning the
most terrible threatening ever born to
man
this message was designed to put the
children of god upon their god and show
them the hour of temptation and anguish
that was before them
said the angel they will be brought into
close combat with the beast and with his
image their only hope of eternal life is
to remain steadfast
although their lives are at stake yet
they must hold fast the truth
the third angel closes his message with
these words
he yes the consciousness of the saints
he are they that keep the commandments
of god
and the faith of jesus
so martin this message
that is given as a final warning to
humanity
where you have to accept the authority
of god is ensconced in the law and
particularly in the sabbath
as opposed to what the beast and the
image is preaching
is the final message
that's it
it was represented to me that the
remnant followed jesus into the most
holy place and beheld the ark now the
ark contains what the law
the law
and the mercy said what is that jesus
covering him with your righteousness
okay so it's justice and mercy kissing
each other
and we're captivated with their glory
jesus raised the cover of the ark and
behold the tables of stone with the ten
commandments were written on them so if
you had rejected the law could you go
into the into the second chamber no
so who were you worshiping in the first
chamber then you're sitting there with
satan he was sitting there with satan
they trace down the lively oracles but
they start back with trembling when they
see the fourth commandment
living among the ten holy precepts while
a brighter light shines upon it than
upon the other nine and a halo of glory
is all around it
there's a lot of criticism over that
text
because if you break one you break them
all why should there be a halo around
the fourth commandment
it was forgotten
and it puts the authority of whose
commandments you are keeping
in other words the entire decalogue
gets its authority from the fourth
commandment
so it must be brighter than the others
because anybody else can give the other
nine okay now who was opposed to the
authority of god
satan satan so wouldn't he try and dim
that commandment definitely
he you you get rid of it that's right so
now it was to become more prominent
and this is the battle
find nothing there informing them that
the sabbath has been abolished or
changed to the first day of the week
it reads as when spoken by the mouth of
god in solomon awful grandeur upon the
mount while the lightnings flashed and
the thunders rolled and when written
with his own holy finger in the tables
of stone
so there are only a very few occasions
as we've said when god wrote with his
finger right
he wrote
in the tables of stone
he wrote on the wall in the fall of
babylon
he wrote in the sand
and each time
it had to do with judgment that's it
okay
i saw the incense and the censor smoke
as jesus offered their confessions and
prayers to his father
and as it ascended a bright light rested
upon jesus and upon the mercy seat and
the earnest praying ones who were
troubled because they had discovered
themselves to be transgressors of god's
law
were blessed and their countenances
lighted up with hope and joy they joined
in the work of the third angel and
raised their voices
and proclaimed the solemn warning so
again you can only proclaim it if you
pass from the first to the second
chamber
but few at first received the message
yet they continued with energy to
proclaim the warning
then i saw many embrace the message of
the third angel and unite their voices
with those who had first proclaimed the
warning
and they exalted god and magnified him
by observing his sanctified rest day
these messages were presented to me as
an anchor to hold the body
and as individuals receive and
understand them they are shielded
against the many delusions of satan
so how important is it that you embrace
all three
you cannot stand against satan
if you don't do this
those words that we had in the previous
one
the gates of hell will not prevail
against the church
this is why you have to embrace all
three messages
okay
so now people will say those that
embrace all three are here embracing a
fairy tale
sounds like a fairy tale
jesus moving from one chamber to another
the law etc etc but if you study it
through it it really is very profound
and it's very logical
but it sounds very judgmental because
you are actually saying that those that
don't go
from the first apartment to the second
department
realizing that law and grace
are to be preached together
are actually then servants of another
power
it sounds judgmental
but the difference is
it's
biblical all right martin
so let's sum it up
the three angels messages that are
preached by the remnant are they
important
yes a matter of life and death right
do they contain a vast amount of
doctrine
the whole gospel is
in those three messages everything
everything because the first angel says
everlasting gospel has to be preached
why would it be necessary to preach the
everlasting gospel again if it had been
preached for thousands of years
obviously it had lost been lost right
satan is a master at separating law and
grace
therefore he is a master of
accommodating those
who want to be saved in their sins
taking
away the law
and
those that want to be saved
without a law
incredible how he does these things
so there is a world lying in wickedness
in deception in delusion
in the very shadow of death asleep
asleep is that a true statement
you just have to look around who are
feeling travail of soul to awaken them
in other words do we feel travail of
soul to say something about it we have
to we we have to right who else if
you're going to be part of the third
angel
then you must have this compulsion to
preach it
we've seen the first second anthem angel
has
a
cry in it
so
if you it will swell but it will a cry
is not a soft little whisper
so what voice can reach them
my mind is carried to the
future when the signal will be given
behold the bridegroom cometh go ye out
to meet him let's just stop there
wasn't that the message in 1844 yes
now
here it says it's going to the future
and this is in 1896 1896.
now martin
can we be a little bit naughty
[Music]
have there been events in the world
that have transpired
in
the last month or years
that gave impetus to the idea behold the
bridegroom is coming
definitely if you had if you missed this
i don't know in which planet you're
living
excuse me i think there are many that
have missed it
because some have said quite plainly
that this is not the final event
but
what has transpired in the last
years
to me
and i believe to you
is a definite pronouncement behold the
bridegroom cometh go ye out to meet him
definitely
i believe it with my whole heart
you know you know martin some people are
as they say at sixes and sevens
but maybe some should be at eight and
nine
but some will have delayed to obtain the
oil for replenishing their lamps and too
late they will find the character which
is represented by the oil
is not transferable so martin the oil
oil stands for the holy spirit
[Music]
but one of the the objects of the holy
spirit is to convict of sin
righteousness and judgment yeah so that
is
accepting the first angel message
already yes and it also means character
then
because if you realize you are a sinner
and you have to correct it
and you realize that you are walking in
unrighteousness and have to turn to
righteousness means there must be a
total transformation of character right
okay
that oil is the righteousness of christ
it represents character and character is
not transferable no man can secure it
for another
each must obtain for himself a character
purified from every stain of sin
the lord is coming in power and great
glory it will then be his work to make a
complete separation between the
righteous and the wicked
but the oil cannot be transferred to the
vessels of those who have it not
then shall be fulfilled the words of
christ two women shall be grinding
the one shall be taken and the other
left two men shall be in the field the
one shall be taken and the other left
the righteous and the wicked are to be
associated together in the work of life
that's a very important statement
but the lord reads the character he
discerns who are obedient children
who respect and love his commandments
so martin the bottom line is
if you are part of the three angels
messages
you will have to realize that there is a
work to be done regarding character
development introspection introspection
so our appeal to the listeners is
behold the bridegroom cometh
we need to be
prepared may god help us to the same
shall we pray
heavenly father
the depth of the three angels messages
the understanding of the times we are
living in
and the importance of the message
may they impress our souls so that me we
would want to be part of their
proclamation
help us to rouse a sleeping people
and help us
to arouse our own consciences
lest we
be lost in the process
prepare us
for the loud cries my prayer in jesus
name amen
[Music]
you